على سفح اعمده كوادريغا المهيبه نزل نحو
عش الاف متظاهر الماني من النقابات
والحركات اليساريه والفنانين وقاده
سياسيين وعلماء الى ميدان بوابه
براندنبورج التاريخي وسط برلين رفضا للحرب
في غزه وتنديدا بموقف الحكومه الالمانيه
منها القياديه والسياسيه الالمانيه
سار كانت صاحبه صوت مرتفع من بين الحضور
في نقد العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه
واعتبرت الائتلاف الحاكمه في المانيا
مثيرا
للشفقه علينا ان نشعر بالصدمه والذهول من
القصف الارعن في غزه وان نشعر بالقدر نفسه
من الخوف والرعب بسبب مقتل النساء
والاطفال الفلسطينيين لا يمكن ان يكون
هناك معياران عندما يموت الناس عندما يموت
الابرياء فهذه جريمه ويجب وقفها هذه الحرب
يجب ان
[موسيقى]
تتوقف تطور كبير في الراي العام الالماني
تجاه ما يجري في غزه رغم محاولات برلين
خنق الاصوات المعتدله او المؤيده
للفلسطينيين فقد كشف استطلاع للراي اجراه
معهد الين سباخ لاستطلاعات الراي ان
76% من الالمان يشعرون بالقلق اتجاه حرب
اسرائيل على غزه ودعى
57% من الالمان
حكومه بلادهم للعب وساطه بين اسرائيل
وحماس بينما رفض 43 في تصريح المستشار
الالماني القائل انه لا يمكن ان يكون هناك
سوى مكان واحد لالمانيا وهو الى جانب
اسرائيل وذهب 38 في من الالمان الى انهم
يشاطرون الراي بان اسرائيل تحتل الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بشكل غير
عادل
هذا التطور في موقف الشعب الالماني بدا
منذ السابع من اكتوبر كان حينها يقف الى
جانب اسرائيل وما لبث ان تراجع عدد
الالمان ممن يوافقون على سلوك اسرائيل في
هذه الحرب الان وبعد مقتل 5 الاف طفل
فلسطيني من مجموع 20 الف مدني في غزه اصبح
المزيد من الالمان لا يتفقون مع الطريقه
التي يخوض بها الاسرائيليون هذه الحرب ما
يجعل هذا سببا اعمق لهذا
التطور سحل واعتقال للناشطين لم يوقف زخم
الحراك المؤيد للفلسطينيين في الشارع ويرى
نشطاء في حركه الحقوق المدنيه الالمانيه
ان ما يجري هو محاوله لثني الالماني عن
ادراك ان غزه
اصبحت الراي العام في المانيا منقسم
للغايه هناك اناس يدعمون اسرائيل دون قيد
او شرط ولكن هناك اشخاص مثلي يدافعون عن
حقوق الفلسطينيين ويعارضون القصف
الاسرائيلي لقطاع غزه اعتقد ان هناك شرخا
في المجتمع الالماني وغزه هي النقطه
المحوريه للازمات العالميه ما يجري في غزه
لا يهم اهلها فقط لقد اصبح مشكله
عالميه كشف استطلاع الراي اختلاف موقف
غالبيه الالمان عن موقف المستشار اولاف
شولتس المتشدد في دعم حرب اسرائيل على غزه
تحت شعار امن اسرائيل مصلحه وطنيه
لبرلين ورغم تخدق اغلب وسائل الاعلام
الالمانيه مع اسرائيل الا ان الراي العامه
في المانيا ياتي مخالفا لاراء الساسه بل
محرجا لهم امام مواطنيهم عيسى طيبي
الجزيره
برلين